all right it's now 6 23 the Winter Fancy
Food Show in Las Vegas is underway right
here this is such a fun event one of the
vendors Frank Florio is the creator of
all this delicious snack stuff cookie
pop candy pop and um I mean talk about
bougie snacks but like right on the
money Frank yes yes it's great it's
great products we're really happy to be
out here in Las Vegas thank you for
having us on and being out here at the
Fancy Food Show yeah where we're
displaying and launching some of our
newest Brand's newest products which is
the cereal pop which has real Fruity
Pebbles on it okay so so just for
everybody at home it's popcorn mixed
with one of the items that you see here
yep yeah with the actual products we
grind up the products uh from the uh
brand managers we bring those in and put
the products right on these uh on the
popcorn so let's talk about the in which
is you know very interesting and I'm
sure delightful and tasty but we're
talking about what makes a good snack at
the fancy foods show there's the all
sorts of different snacks and various
other things and fancy foods what makes
a good snack I think it has to be
something that uh the consumer is not
only going to see immediately with the
bag and the and and being attracted to
it but obviously anything good has to be
open and once you start eating it has to
be something that you want to continue
to eat and then chasing the flavor and
finding it throughout the bag and I say
the sweet and savory okay now I got the
go ahead that I can open a bag so here
here's what's gonna happen because this
is M M's and popcorn correct and to me
this is something that I've been doing
at the movie theater for so long that um
people always said you're gonna do that
what and then they have it and then they
can't get enough so I already know that
this one is going to be definitely my
jam and how important is is it a
convention like this we have here in Las
Vegas to just sort of the snack industry
it's a big deal oh yeah absolutely
buyers Distributors Brokers all show up
they try to find what's new what's
trendy and fancy food's always been uh
very good at that you know and we have
probably a couple you know it's probably
a thousand fifteen hundred uh other
companies like myself there and uh to be
able to be in front of a buyer be in
front of the event uh the other Brokers
and Distributors is very important to us
now regular people like me and John can
actually go peruse around and I'm
guessing you're going to have little
taste testers and all that kind of stuff
you could eat your way through the whole
show it's amazing tomorrow so you can so
basically buy a ticket and we could just
go eat all day sounds like a plan to me
I kind of like that absolutely we got to
talk about this though because this is
something that caught my eye a
gluten-free plant-based what are those
those are a snack that's shaped like a
penny like a penne and uh it's a
snackable gray product gluten-free like
you said made out of lentil and it's
just a really exciting product that has
great flavor profiles to it and the
lentil
that's correct yes there is I'm trying
to find ways to make snacks more
nutritional which is a smart idea uh
Frank thanks for joining us today you're
talking about your own products here the
big fancy foods event taking place here
which is great here in Las Vegas just
some of the cool things yeah make sure
you go to Sam's Club we're launching
this at Sam's Club oh it's in the store
right now because it's Smith's right and
Smith's yes Smith's in here in Las Vegas
awesome and we do donate a percentage of
all our proceeds to the Ryan Seacrest
Foundation anymore and feel better about
it awesome great thank you thank you
very much